do you have to pay federal income tax on
those Taylor Swift tickets you sold
technically yeah that's what federal law
says tickets to Swift's insanely popular
eras tour averaged more than $3,800 a
piece on the secondary market and thanks
to the American Rescue plan anything you
sold online for more than $600 old
furniture cool guitar even those concert
tickets is subject to federal taxes but
the IRS just announced that it's
postponing enforcement of that provision
for the second year in a row they worry
that too many taxpayers could be
confused by the new rules and it is
confusing and silly the new threshold
mostly targets low-income Americans who
don't have accountants the old threshold
of $20,000 in income or 200 online
transactions was sufficient to capture
anyone earning real money but the new
rules mean people selling art on Etsy or
making a little extra cash driving for
Uber could become federal tax criminals
just because they failed to fill out the
right form